even though you're working your your uh
jab cross combination don't don't go to
uh hip and shoulder okay it's still
ground so I I won't throw it at his
space but boom it's still ground it
should still boom displace okay it
should still displace okay so boom it
should go into his body so I have to
ground back boom
boom boom boom think about
your this is more angles as opposed to
hip rotation shoulder strength okay it's
more angles boom right up this middle
boom right through this side but your
your engine is still on the
ground okay let's
try all right so when I'm holding the
bag I can do a lot of my own stuff so I
get used to this what it looks like how
to read it okay so you can see yeah I'm
fighting uh Southpaw here for me but I
can still be in a good stance I can
still have the other hand up I can make
sure my eyes open just don't put this in
front of you okay and so as he's going I
can also time it so a little slower boom
so you can see I'm hitting him as much
as he's hitting me
and when I hit him I'm just pawing it
paw
P okay try this time I'm going to take
the jab across but this one's going to
be a a flicker jab okay so I'm not it
goes through the eyes but I I want
something a little soft feel but it's
the same thing it's not a wimpy strip my
body boom my body and my ground Vector
are in it okay and then the next one is
going to be a palm heel after you hit
the Palm heel the eyes the fingers go in
the eyes too so there're two one quick
eyes pump Pop Eyes okay same thing
ground sorry okay ground get this angle
boom
boom boom boom pop
okay let's
try so I'm finding Le hand down and my
front leg is kind of loaded okay so if
he when he moves into range right boom I
might be able to get the inner thigh
right boom to take his base out so and
I'm
in or I might even get a slip kick on
the groin okay whatever reason I don't
feel I can do it so I got to Paw the jab
it comes the one two boom I got to get
off the line so we shoot 10 con okay get
off the line you would do that anyways
if he's trying to uh get a beat on you
keep moving this way
okay so you're going to go one two there
you go okay so I'm here I don't
know just get your shoulder up cuz your
hand is down okay so here I'm out 10 con
t con okay try all right so this strike
is a looping back knuckle so I can throw
it to the depends if he penetrates bar
I'll hit the back of the mastoid or I'll
hit the temple or anywhere on the face
is going to do what I want it to do okay
so it's not a hook I'm kind of out of
position you see my hook should be
tighter so one Bo and I just hit now you
started that rotation okay so he has to
get a be back back on me you see so
that's what I want so
Bo this comes my kick to the body so one
boom around
boom boom pop and
boom get these angles while 1 2
3om okay let's
go so
go when I take this kick don't pivot
here me and that sets up your mind okay
so if you was back further then I would
Ed me here and then my kick would be
there if he's close then I would me back
here and then oh my kick is there again
okay got it don't so don't do it in
place because it's probably not going to
be in place you're going to have to get
your mind
okay so angles angles and it's short so
when I what I mean as short is I don't
need that big angle to make him Miss so
as I'm working my drill I'm more close
okay and that's going to make that more
important so he's barely missing me you
see maybe even feeling a little bit of
it to get it to go
boom right here you can feel it boom and
and then the timing one boom it should
hit on that movement and then the time
there shouldn't be a pop on my kick
coming in I can't be going one 2 3 4 5
the timing between the
strike and the kick has to be pretty
immediate okay try
F put it at floating rib
right okay and then you me 10 come so
turn him sideways diagonal like his body
was I'm not fighting him this is his
ribs I'm going to step and into the
Ki same thing
ground move his
mat okay let's go